Euh, quoi
eww
Hmm
cout
un 5
5 5 5 5 5 5 5
5 5 5 5 5 5 5 5 5 5
sur
bois
huile de bois
avec
notre
plus tôt cette année
regarder
à
de faible
heure 5
woo ah
OMS
propre
Ah, maman, respire sur la lune et la terre
eww
être
de a à b 2
ou 5 5
la face
Quand il n'y a pas
oo secondes 5 het ook
Il était déjà 5 heures
ah
leur hôtel
C'est vrai, papa
Ce point est cool alors
holo oui
ah
asou
Je ne sais rien, le football
aussi
qui chante w ah ou ensemble ou
l'amour ami a écrit Largo
eww
Que fais-tu en ce moment?
Ah, ça suffit maintenant
Qu'est-ce que tu es, Jiwoo, vas-y, vas-y 2
abaisse-le
tu es toujours
Euh euh
ah
ct lechon
Il n'y a pas de 4ème voiture à Hauvre Clos
10 sacs de colle que j'ai fait oh oh oh
toro oui maya
Oui
eww
numéro tonga
Oh oh oh oh maintenant
sur
bientôt 5
ooh ooh mon bien
bois
ooh, ami pour toujours
courtiser
5 Comme s'il flottait et se reposait, chérie, w
nombre
ah
wong
que
Euh euh ah euh
Pouah 5
ver
Hmm